sachez que le secteur privé et va
prendre de l'ampleur à cuba bon nombre
d'activités privées s'apprête à être
autorisé dans l'île des caraïbes une
mesure approuvée un conseil des
ministres
si depuis 2014 et les réchauffements des
relations avec les etats-unis une liste
autorisée plus de 120 activités être
exercée dans le privé celle ci n'y va
disparaître et ce sont désormais la
plupart des secteurs qui seront ouverts
à cette activité privée on en parle en
direct avec thomas pour s'adonner des
docteurs en sciences politiques et
coauteur de révolution à cuba de 1868 à
nos jours bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors l'activité
privée sera désormais autorisée dans la
majorité des secteurs
un changement de taille qui j'imagine va
modifier l'économie du pays tout à fait
alors elle évolue déjà cette économie
cubaine
de plus en plus de secteurs été confiée
à l'économie de marché et on avait un
cheminement lent qui se faisait vers une
restauration de l'économie de marché
depuis maintenant plusieurs dizaines
d'années alors c'est un cheminement lens
est pas du tout l'ampleur de ce qui a pu
connaître la chine ou le vietnam il ya
quelques décennies mais cette mesure
qu'on couplée avec celle de
l'unification monétaire qui a été décidé
le 1er janvier a tendance à accroître
cette cette restauration d'économie de
marché
alors ça va créer de l'emploi dans quel
secteur
alors ce que recherche l'emploi que
recherche
cuba s'est dont tourisme et c'est toute
la difficulté de l'économie cubaine en
ce moment c'est que le secteur
touristique est profondément sinistré du
avec les sanitaires
on prévoyait 5 millions de touristes
l'année dernière en 2020 et u 15
millions de touristes qui sont arrivés
dans l'île et c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle les
militant récession de 11% sur l'année
2020 et ces secteurs qui sont les plus
dynamiques secteur touristique notamment
en raison de l'embargo des états unis
donc c'est en cela qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur sur le quel va être
le contenu de cette réforme à cuba parce
que de fait les investissements sont
très limités à cuba et le commerce
extérieur qui connaît pas le détail 1 de
la liste des activités qui qui seront
réservés à l'éteindre mais normalement
le commerce extérieur devrait re est
réservée à l'état et donc les
possibilités d'importer interdite pour
les cubains et est ce que ça veut dire
que les cubains pourront créer leur
entreprise et être leur propre patron
oui alors mais c'est déjà le cas c'était
déjà le cas dans un certain nombre de
secteurs vous mentionnez bien en
introduction la seule différence c'est
qu'avant en donner la liste des secteurs
qui étaient autorisés à à
l'entreprenariat privé et là maintenant
on fait la liste des secteurs qui sont
exclues de l'entreprenariat privé ça
reste des toutes petites entreprises un
de quelques salariés et ça reste des
entreprises
d'une dimension enfin kiki qui n'ont pas
cette possibilité de faire de l'import
export
mais ce cette possibilité existait déjà
on a déjà une quinzaine 2% de la
population active qui travaillent dans
le secteur privé aujourd'hui à cuba
alors vous me disiez tout à l'heure que
bas touchés par la pandémie privé de ses
touristes
à quel point la crise sanitaire a frappé
l économie cubaine
un belge que je disais c'est que c'est
ainsi c'est que l'un des secteurs qui
est le plus frappé par la crise inter
c'est le secteur touristique et cuba
dépendant énormément du tourisme c'est
le troisième poste de de ressources de
davis de devises pour l'état derrière
l'airé mais ça c'est des transferts
d'argent et l'envoi de deux brigades
médical à l'étranger c'est eu un manque
à gagner énorme cuba essaye de
redynamiser le tourisme en ce moment en
s'appuyant justement sur son savoir
faire médical et à relancer la
possibilité d'un vaccin qui serait
offert du
aux touristes qui viendrait dans l'île
alors ce vaccin il n'est pas encore en
circulation il est en phase iii de test
mais il serait potentiellement quelque
chose qui pourrait aider à redynamiser
le tourisme
maintenant on est dans une situation où
cette crise sanitaire n'est pas réglée
et où cuba qui a longtemps été épargnée
par cette crise sanitaire connaît sa
première vague maintenant en fait de
deux copies de 19 avec une reprise des
de la contamination en ce moment et où
on a de nouvelles mesures restrictives
et un couvre-feu qui a été déclaré ces
tout derniers jours
joe biden récemment élu président à
américain dans quelle mesure ça peut
modifier changer les relations entre
cuba et son voisin américain
on peut espérer que cette élection de
joe biden améliore les relations entre
les etats-unis et cuba en dessert le
blocus qui asphyxie l'économie cubaine
donald trump a été impitoyable jusqu'à
la dernière minute de son mandat contre
l'économie cubaine en classant notamment
cuba sur la liste des pays soutenant le
terrorisme ce que barack obama mais
avait supprimé et en renforçant toutes
les sanctions contre contre cuba joe
biden pendant sa campagne s'est engagé à
revenir sur toutes les mesures de donald
trump sur cet aspect là après on verra
ce qu'il est possible de faire parce que
le sénat garde des minorités de blocage
en faveur des républicains qui sont très
réticents à avancer sur cette question
et la nomination comme secrétaire d'état
a donc misé affaires étrangères aux
états unis dans tony blinken qui est
jugé comme un néo conservateur qui est
jugé comme quelqu'un qui voulait
intervenir en irak en syrie en libye
n'est pas forcément la nomination la
plus propice à une reprise du dialogue
avec avec cuba maintenant toute
l'incertitude réside dans quelle sera la
décision de dubaï guen et son pouvoir
discrétionnaire permettrait de faire
avancer les choses sur ces aspects là
thomas fausse ados merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes docteur en sciences politiques et
kotor des évolutions à cuba de 1868 à
nos jours a retrouvé aux éditions
syllepse merci à vous